[Música]
se você fosse morrer hoje tivesse
direito a uma última refeição o que você
comeria e se você pudesse convidar 13
pessoas para compartilhar essa reflexão
convencer quem seria e agora e mais
importante reflexão quando foi a última
vez que você compartilhou refeição com
essas três pessoas que você pensou agora
quando foi que você recebe um evento da
sua vida pra agradar essa pessoa pra não
cair pra dar uma atenção e jogar
conversa fora
vamos pensar nisso
vamos olhar para dentro antes de olhar
em volta e olhar também para dentro a
gente tem que refletir e assumir o nosso
papel é uma responsabilidade sobre a
nossa felicidade ea comida é a refeição
pode ser um caminho e libertador e de
recolha é sobre isso que eu falo com
vocês hoje a gente vive na era da
informação
já descobrimos hoje que vivemos talvez
nós estamos num processo de viver em uma
outra é ainda mais avançada com a
tecnologia muito mais presente mas a era
da informação trouxe uma mudança
significativa
nessa em dúvida nas nossas vidas a gente
se desconectou das relações reais para
se conectar no mundo virtual
então a gente tem 5 mil talvez né com
essa exposição em mídia eu tenho eu já
não sei mais quantas milhares de amigos
mas com quantos eu posso contar a
verdade para quantos eu posso ligar no
momento de indecisão no momento que eu
preciso de um conselho quem liga
hoje em dia é obrigação virou declaração
de amor
até mesmo uma refeição compartilhada o
que ela significa pensar muito sobre
isso hoje 5 um dado em amor líquido fala
sobre ela a mentalidade do valor das
pessoas nas nossas vidas
é tudo muito rápido muito veloz
a gente quer sempre a próxima aventura
né qual será o próximo amor
qual será o próximo produto que eu vou
construir nem qual será o próximo
artista que vão consumir a gente acumula
amigos nas redes sociais
e eu acho que talvez muitos
antidepressivos mesmo e de que maneira
isso pode começar a mudar
olhando olhando e olhando pra conhecer
suas paixões buscando o que te faz feliz
o que te faz bem o seu propósito de vida
e eu encontrei o meu propósito é foi
engraçado eu não me lembrava que tinha
uma descrição detalhada e tenho de mim e
rodando por aí mas eu descobri um amor
pela cozinha e que esse amor ele pode
mover as relações em outros níveis
eu comecei pequena porque na minha
família é uma cozinheira de mão cheia
então precisa uma cozinha nef foi criada
como mãe dando tudo em tudo na mão
quando foi morar sozinha e nem sei por
que essa valorosa e aprendi a cozinhar
isso foi tomando vida
depois disso a produção é claro tomar
conta da sua vida do que os hobbies né
ea gente tenta equilibrar o equilíbrio é
a palavra chave
tudo isso que está falando hoje de olhar
em volta
olhar pra dentro desse papel mundo se
rever no mundo tem de construir novas
relações
então a comida a refeição em família é
um lugar que explora e que você consegue
cultivar é tudo isso relações podem
curar
como eu fui curada a gente não pode em
nenhum momento manter os nossos olhos
somente na tela do celular
a gente tem que realmente olhar para
fora
e como é que eu fui curada procurada
pela cozinha mas em especial que eu fui
curada por uma família por uma família
que foi resgatada
dessa família o meu irmão fernando e
fazer quatro anos e chegou pra gente com
um ano de idade
ele foi multado e claro que a gente não
sabe explicar mas uma pessoa que foi
abandonada veio pra gente poder do amor
e ele não aceita que ninguém fique
sozinho numa reeleição um ambiente
se ele tivesse aqui que não atrase até
aqui na frente porque ele pegar pela
manhã fazer pra cá essa criança entrou
nas nossas vidas para nos ensinar o
verdadeiro significado da palavra
comunhão da palavra do verbo
compartilhar da palavra dos ativos
família ea gente descobriu isso uma data
afinal de contas a nossa vida ela é
construída a partir das refeições a
gente não se dá conta a rotina de
trabalho elas r a partir das refeições
café da manhã e intervalos da manhã
almoço jantar
a gente trabalha nesse meio tempo a
gente tem horários do que para voltar a
trabalhar para voltar a arrancar fazer
as refeições arraes dadas comemorativas
todas elas existem ao redor de uma
refeição e vindo de uma família de pais
separados a esses momentos eles foram se
esvaindo
quando o fernando chegou no primeiro
natal é impossível a gente pensar em se
separar
então de um momento de uma família que é
a maneira
dispunha né não se dispunha é que estava
junto tanto tempo a gente resolveu que
ia mudar e tivemos o primeiro natal em
família com a mãe e um pai que são
separados em que fosse com meu pai com a
mãe que estão juntos que tem um filho
que é apaixonado pela primeira esposa
ele mandou uma carta de natal pra minha
mãe e ela respondeu é uma das coisas
mais lindas de veio então uma pessoa
como eu disse que vem de um histórico
que a gente nem fazia ideia que viveu
abandonada na pele veio nos ensinar que
a gente tinha que deixar todas as malas
para trás para ver de fato a família e
como eu descobri que isso é possível
através das refeições porque nesses
momentos que a gente não abriu mão no
dia a dia a gente deixa passar né a
rotina às vezes faz a gente esquecer que
esses momentos são importantes
a gente passa ao lado de gente como faz
fonte ea gente esquece de nada tempo que
a gente vive assim quanto mais a gente
conseguiu disponibilizar tempo para
viver em família para viver com amigos
momentos inesquecíveis
eu acho surgir porque aqui é muito
gostoso que sejam as refeições
sempre quanto mais vocês fizerem isso
más memórias feliz vocês terão porque a
gente não tem com a memória feliz então
faz food meu cérebro não precisa se
esforçar para guardar aquela lembrança é
o mesmo sabor que eu senti essa semana
daqui a um mês
daqui a dez anos exatamente a mesma
experiência
eu não preciso guardar aquilo na memória
mais um momento especial um momento que
me toca
esse sim vai ficar guardada pra mim
despedida por exemplo tem outro de
bolinho de chuva porque a minha tia em
que meninas lá de casa
na casa dela ela não faça enquanto eu
estou de chuva pra voltar pra casa
quando chegou aqui com a gente conta a
história do que eu fui lá pra mim
saudade de despedida vai fazer uma
relação rasa rápida nenhum momento no
celular vai trazer essa lembrança
gosto de volta então pense nisso
a refeição é um ato de relações jogo de
volta no celular da comida e vamos tirar
foto da gente não tinha fotos dos
momentos
agora o melhor de tudo não vamos tirar
fotos
vamos viver esses momentos
ae vamos deixar de ligar no celular para
alguns não é por uma hora
um domingo vai fazer toda a diferença
nas nossas vidas
então agora eu lanço um desafio pra
vocês e pra todos nós eu também vou
levar esse desafio
israel está envolta em momentos
especiais que a gente viva em família
compartilhando sentimentos resgatando
relações e nos curando de qualquer de
qualquer mágoa de qualquer ranço de
qualquer um sentimento negativo que a
gente já tenha tido algum dia quando
você vê o que realmente importa quando
você coloca na balança
você vê que vale a pena filó e que
aquele momento vai ser lembrado para
sempre vai ficar na memória de todos
olhar em volta
adriana
[Aplausos]